with the arrival of season 2 of apex
legends the weapon meta has changed
tremendously flipping the weapon tier
list on its head this even makes the
Mozambique a viable weapon making the
meme surrounding the gun kind of
obsolete now
ouch baby very well go over the overall
changes first then go into our opinion
about the meta in general the biggest
change so far are the two new hop ups
introduced the disruptor and the hammer
point rounds give a new twist to gunplay
making hot swapping a great tactic
depending on if the enemy has shields or
nose shields disruptor rounds attached
to the alternator and the re 45 and have
the ability to shred through armor it is
a 1.7 damage multiplier previously was
broken at 2.262 armor specifically then
ax does normal damage to non armored
opponents with the base damage and the
barrel recoil reduced even more the
alternator makes a great contender to
its big brother the r99
hammer point rounds attached to the P
2020 and the Mozambique and do regular
damage against armored opponents then
start hitting for a whopping two to two
point six times damage multiplier
against non armoured opponents if you
get your hands on both of these hop ups
with the respective weapons it's quite a
force to be reckoned with
also always remember to aim down the
sights with the Mozambique it tightens
up your pellet spread the brand new
weapon the L star is a heck of a weapon
as well but the high recoil and the
bright energy rounds may make it hard to
see the enemy remember to try and
feather your trigger halfway through the
clip so you don't overheat the weapon
the flatline received a simple damage
buff well does it make it the best gun
in the game it's not something to scoff
at it can tear through enemies quickly
as long as you can control its high
recoil energy weapons in general are
also much more viable now with larger
and most acts to carry extended energy
mags making the havoc and devotion a DPS
machine and even increase reload speeds
with blue and purple magazines shotguns
have also been balanced out not in fire
power button carry capacity with the
previous 64 shotgun rounds per stack it
would usually be able to carry you
through the game leaving tons of room
for other goodies in your bag for the
cap of 16 shots per stack now this may
make the Peacekeeper a more viable
option than the Eva eight just because
it chews through less ammo with the
previous longbow buff choke charge time
reduced for the triple take and crater
damage buff even more all snipers are
rising an overall value and add a lot
more pressure in long-range fights
in our opinion every gun has a place in
the meta now but the Aria 45 and the
alternator with the hop-up seem to rise
slightly above the rest even after the
nerf with massive damage output a close
and medium ranges there used to be a
more distinct ladder from stronger to
weaker weapons but with these newest
updates is more about better positioning
out playing your opponent and playing
with their current weapons strengths
[Music]